Alina Polyakova,
president and CEO of the Center
for European Policy Analysis.
She has done
extensive reporting on Putin
and his inner circle.
So, Alina, I'm glad to have you back.
You know, we just played
that sound a moment ago
from Putin's alleged girlfriend, mother
of multiple of his children.
And I want to play it again
emotional now.
But honestly,
looking information work
under the conditions
that we are currently living
and as we fight for our country
is like a weapon of war.
And in terms of significance,
it holds
no less value than a Kalashnikov.
Kalashnikov.
What is she really saying here?
Well, I think a few things.
One, the whole idea
that information warfare
or the use of disinformation
is part and parcel
of how Russia engages in war.
It's not just about the tanks.
It's not just about the Kalashnikovs,
as she says.
It's also about skewing the narrative
and skewing the very idea
of what's happening
in Russia's war against Ukraine.
This is nothing new.
She's really reconfirming
what has been official Kremlin policy.
I think the second takeaway here
is something that she alludes to,
which is, of course,
that we are looking at almost a year
since Russia's
full scale invasion of Ukraine.
And I think she says
at the beginning that
now we need this win,
something along those lines.
And what she is really saying
there is this war
for Russia, the war
the Russia
of Putin have launched against Ukraine
is really an existential war for Putin
and for Russia itself.
And many Russians
today inside of Russia do believe
that this is a war that they have to win.
It's a nationalist war.
They believe wrongly, of course, that Mr.
Putin is protecting them.
And, Alina,
for anyone who had hoped that
maybe she would have
I don't know,
turned sides
or just decided to remain in Switzerland,
you know,
this obviously shows that's not the case.
It took a long time for the United States
to put any sanctions on her whatsoever.
They finally did
they thought it would make,
you know, too incendiary to Putin,
but she is now sanctioned.
How influential is she?
Does she does she carry much sway?
Obviously,
We know who
she seems to be vis a vis him.
And then along with that,
she got these titles,
you know, like head of some of these
crucial media companies.
Well, to be clear, she
is definitely a known name in Russia.
I mean, she's Putin's
girlfriend, mistress,
whatever you want to call her,
or for that reason,
whatever she says
does get reported
in the Russian tabloids.
But in terms of having
political influence, she really doesn't.
I mean, she is here basically
reframing,
repeating what is a Kremlin
talking point.
But she is a recognizable name.
Of course,
the sanctions have probably forced her
to go back to Russia and leave
what we believe
was the very opulent lifestyle.
She was living in Switzerland,
where she now
is the chair of this new media group.
But everyone knows inside of Russia
that she's only there
because she is
the mother of Putin's children.
So she gets paid millions of dollars
for basically doing
absolutely nothing
except making
a few PR appearances here and there.
Amazing.
All right, Alina, thank you very much.
Good to see you again. And thanks.